[Music]
this lecture is gonna be about my games
because I'm the lecturer if you don't
like it go to another youtube channel
and I'll be on that one too
it's gonna be about the d4 pawn and the
d4 square so after 64 lectures you guys
will be great ok this one's about this
square now a lot of times you have an
isolated pawn not you guys because you
guys hang all your pawns but we have an
isolated pawn it's weak however you can
have a weak pawn that's not isolated
because it can't be protected by other
pawns now this is a game that I was
playing Fabiola Roda who's actually an
American player now but he was he was
cubed at the KB's Columbian sorry and I
first met Fabio in 1988 at this
tournament anyway he actually played the
US Championship many years later he
snuck in by some senior rule I don't
know some qualified okay but he's a
typical 2,300 type player and I was 18
and I was trying to get better now I can
actually give an hour lecture on this
tournament this was the world chess
festival and they had candidates matches
they had international tournaments like
this one and at a very famous blitz
tournament and then we'll be happy to
hear about this the blitz tournament had
a first prize of $50,000 like low splits
tournaments and all the top players in
the world played and it was a knockout
and in semi finals
Kiril you are Jeff was playing Rafael
vogue onion and Vogon yan was was
winning let's see which side was he he
was winning and he had a rook and pawn
ending where he had two pawns as Epona
had no pawns the two pawns is better
then he made a move and went to hit the
clock leaving his King in check and his
opponent took his King so he wins and he
was like ah but he was like wait a
minute I didn't hit my clock but no
he knew whether he hid his clock then
the guy took the king and hid it or he
didn't hit it yet
but they had the video replay they were
videotaped at the games in 88 and they
actually did a replay and he saw his
hand go of this and then go I never hit
the clock by not hitting the clock his
move isn't illegal yet they had to keep
playing for that position he won and he
won the event he beat all actually he
lost at all in the finals to all beat
him 4-0 or three and a half half
depending on the results of the last
game which isn't clear because they they
just said the game ended and that ended
the match so three and a half won the
match so it's not clear what happened
but anyway that server had Karpov and
Kasparov and it had my favorite first
round pairing Karpov Sherazi
as a good pairing okay not good for
Sherazi but good pairing and Kasparov
famously had Queen and Bishop versus
nothing and still made it his opponent I
was watching it so that was queue of
jurgen he lost that match ok so I was
playing Fabiola rota in this tournament
I played him twice because they made
great parent no because there were two
international tournaments because there
were so it was a month long the
tournament and one of the international
tournaments was won by Joel Benjamin
because as we all know it's all about
the Benjamins and he took us out to
dinner that's pretty awesome
there were a lot of us okay so this was
one of the few games I won because I
mainly lost to this tournament I was
black in a caro-kann I my opponent
played the advanced variation which
always been popular and he played h4
like I'm nobody and nobody played it
back then but now they play it
especially mvl so edge 4 is popular I
played h5 and my opponent decided he was
going to win my H pawn and he did hooray
for him he won my H pawn so he played 92
he's gonna play Knight g3 and Bishop e2
and take my pawn ok but I've lost pawns
before especially 1988 then I lost a lot
of funds and I counter-attacked in the
center ok and that's sort of the theme
of the lecture today is attacking the d4
pawn so I attack the d4 pawn ok and I
put my knight on f5
somehow which was the style at the time
and I saved my H Pend Oreille okay and
the reason that black is better here is
white has a weak D pawn and black does
not and the other reason is positional
in nature my bishops are pretty good
this Bishop on e3 is a little iffy but
that Bishop is needed because we have to
defend our d4 pawn my d4 pawn is
protected by a pawn so I'm good okay and
then he played Bishop d3 which trades
off his good Bishop for my my bad bishop
but I was a very sneaky young player
okay they caught me sneaking a lot and I
played a move that I would never play
now because I have a lot of rules that
to follow now by following all of my
rules I don't even play anymore I can't
say any move I make breaks a lot of
rules so I gotta just lecture now I made
a move of any student played I would
never stop yelling at them I would yell
at them for exactly one hour why is that
Matt get paid by the hour
very good I'm not yelling for an hour
and one minute because i wouldnt get
paid for that minute okay
I played Bishop takes c3 track which is
the best move but that's what I was good
now that I have a lot of rules I would
never play that move now the reason it's
good is white cannot recapture he played
the very subtle in-between move king c2
very subtle okay
well if he takes with a pawn then when I
trade bishops my knight goes to c4 and I
have an advantage right yeah so he took
with the King and because he has to take
with a king now I attack rook c8
threatening discovered everything with
advantage so he played Bishop e5 pinning
my knight and I should have played
double discovered check confusing the
opponent Knight takes e5 double check
but I played a legal move rook a five
and he played a four and will will start
here for our our advanced lecture but
what blacks are playing win oh my god
I'm missing a period was it wasn't a
period
guy didn't we hire one stealing Perrier
also what's the vacuum budget for this
place you even come with out that was
funny
yes rook takes Bishop the terrible
descriptive notation but 1988 so you
gonna break rug digs b5 exclaimed double
axe clam he played the best move and
this was when I was young so I could
really calculate man I could see stuff
back in the day what did I do
that's not a chess move the sacks the
exchange of them things later
if holy Spencer was here so he could
sack the exchange in Russian please very
good because he had the accident then ok
Knight d4 Chuck King takes Knight is
risky due to Rick see for me all other
King moves are also risky they all lose
a lot of material
he played back to d2 and every move wins
that's my kind of position but I played
the best move now if his King goes to
the first rank I take the rook for free
so he goes the second rank then if I
take the rook he takes back so I throw
in a check then again if he goes to the
first rank I take the rook so he goes
here and now White has a fine game ok
King e1 double exclamation mark
threatening to castle either way now
it's funny is if he cancels Queen side
it's made damn didn't see that coming
castles made okay I played rook takes b2
now if his rook goes off the first rank
I play rugby 1 check so he stayed on the
first rank and I played Bishop c2 so his
game gets better and better
no ok and then he resigned for obvious
reasons now it's funny is uh there's the
winning move o to take on D for that
week D pawn boy that was great
ok my D pawn was good so by having
him defend the deep on the whole game
with Bishop III and Bishop to b5 then he
losing position King was too exposed and
if he had played the tactically better
move pawn takes which doesn't get maded
then when we get this endgame just just
terrible for white my Knight goes to c4
my rook can go to c4 and his and his a
pawn is weak on the open line and his
Bishop is you know terrible just
fighting against the pawns so that was
one of my only wins in the event except
I beat him in the other international
also so he was my favorite opponent okay
every other game is a travesty right
trap was a travesty yeah not a tragedy
mind you okay next game was played in
1992 that says Germany versus Germany
very suspicious but actually it was at
the US Open which was in Dearborn
Michigan
Spencer remembers it well it was in
August of 92 okay I played so Bailey
that event he was crying like a baby
okay now actually during that event I
don't think Spencer remembers this I was
getting a TV home and I had him in the
other arm and I fell on the ice so that
was a a good situation there okay
the doctor said he might have brain
damage okay okay so for those of you who
showed up late this lecture is about
white having a weak D for area and then
me punishing it or my opponent but not
my opponent okay so this is the US Open
in 1992 and I used to play the Estonian
Defence named after mr. Estonia Paul
Kara's okay
also Joe's not too happy right yeah I
think you lost in 10 losers yeah I
didn't see the you told me about it
right I used to play Bishop F on I had
white and black in this position but I
preferred to have white okay
my opponent played Knight c3 which is
fine there's other moves and we played
in this way you could also play 96 if
you're crazy and I played knight c6 many
times but c6 is a bit more solid Bishop
f4 is a bit
and now I play Queen b6 and there's no
defense to beat sue so my opponent
resigned no not really
he played Queen b3 strangely I've had
this position many times even though
Bishop f4 is a stupid move and the way
for blacks to get the advantage is very
strange
it's to totally give the center away
with the move D takes c4 obviously Queen
takes c4 runs into Queen takes b2 but
why can just take and play e4 and Bishop
takes c4 looks good but it's not good
because blacks gonna play b5 and B for
AB Bishop b4 and Knight f6 and totally
destroy white Center which is what I
what I try to do obviously why doesn't
want to play e5 because then his center
is totally blocked and my bishop on g6
is great so he defends and actually
White's just defending his Center if you
remember the theme of this lecture which
I told you two minutes ago so you
probably forgot it is the week d4 pawn
and by him defending his e4 pawn now his
D for puns week so I get to gain a tempo
attacking it rip to d8 I'm surprised I
didn't Castle a queen so I like to do
stuff like that and he played 9 to b3
and I played 9 to d5 I learned this
trick from Luke Wynans who was the only
Belgian Grandmaster when I lived in
Belgium and now some guys moved to
Belgium so there's some other Belgian
grandmasters but he always told me when
you're bishops on g6 if there's a white
queen on g3 or c2 or a bishop on d3 you
have this trick Knight to d5
well white doesn't want to take the
knight black will have two bishops at a
better center so he moved his bishop and
once again I'm attacking his d4 pawn
because that's the lecture now his
knight on B 3 is defending it but his d4
pawn is pinned so if I get to play e5 or
c5 safely he has trouble capturing Rick
d1 trying to defend on the D line night
c4 attacking the B to pawn obviously
Bishop c1 so he played Bishop f4
2 g 5 2 D 2 2 c1 okay every square but
Bishop e3 defending the pawn be 5
finally okay and now I'm gonna get all
the dark squares on the Queen side when
that pawn goes away I'll have all these
squares from my bishop in my knight and
black just has an advantage but I just
has a nice position now he went a little
crazy because he hadn't gone crazy yet
so it was about time he played Bishop b1
okay and which French player should have
white here back row very good okay this
should be one if you're here last
lecture you would have gotten that okay
or if you would have said the answer he
would've gotten it okay Bishop to f7 I
like retreating also castles takes
Bishop c5 uh-oh and now the d4 pawn is
gone but I still attack d4 92 castles
and yeah you could see White's positions
very suspicious and passive and bad king
h1 out of the pin I double rooks on the
D file he doesn't let me because he's
mean and 93 that was a very nice trick I
played so here he looks like he's going
to trade all the pieces and just be
worse because III is weak but I played
93 first and I take all of his pieces
and then the director came up during the
game and said by the way this is
giveaway so I resigned okay and I took
everything and I took this okay and he
resigned here because down the exchange
and worse so that was a game where I was
attacking d4 the whole time and he was
defending it the whole time and it was
very much in the hyper modern style of
AI of the center I attacked a center the
center crumbles and I won so yeah he got
his nice center here F 3 and E 4 but his
bishop was stuck on b1 okay and those
were the days when I could actually play
chess thanks YouTube all that tournament
who would have thunk that now my two
favorite games this one especially
certain people such as oh I don't know
Matt Larsen could learn from this game
okay this game I needed a draw for clear
first place
my opponent offered me a draw I declined
and then he laughed okay and then I left
all the way to the bank
and somebody's like why are you walking
to the bank laughing I was like I don't
know okay so I'm black and I'm playing
Aria levy or as he's known in Michigan
Levi's okay and at that time and this is
not a joke although it is but it's not I
had a Chevy true so I drove my chevy to
play levy but let me resigned okay
anyway so I'm black and I played my
usual boring you know boring world of
niels bohr okay
and he played d4 which is unusual
normally they play d3 Knight bTW - and
then Lake thomashefsky and pond Oh like
shrug their shoulders I guess it's a
draw okay yeah so okay he played d4
which is very good for my lecture
because the d4 is weak okay and I took
the night and I'm solid okay and this is
the game I lost 2l vested 90 moves I
think and he played Eve for now if he
wanted to draw he should probably move
his pieces around in a circle okay and
then offer a draw and I would decline
but he played efore going for the
advantage or as I would say playing for
the disadvantage because now d4 is
permanently weak as you will notice over
the next 10 15 moves and now I calm
skied it up which means I played well I
don't do that anymore so I can't say it
but when I was younger I would I would
probably calm ski I'd beat everybody and
I would play the same openings he would
even though he wasn't born yet I still
did it so after all these trades the d4
pawn is weak and you can't defend d4
with another pawn so I'm gonna put all
my pieces on d4 and I did
okay that's that's about as much as I
could take it to a little more and the
problem is why can't do anything why
just waits around and I'm gonna play
Knight d6 Knight f5 and I'm gonna take
that d4 pawn eventually or c5 or Queen
b6 I'm gonna keep nah go back to chess
piece that won't possibly work okay
there we go
now at some point he had to give
everything away he defended I played a 5
now you'll notice he takes e5 is risky
because his rooks hanging right not true
so he played d5 and now F 5 and this is
how calm skews to win when he played in
the u.s. championship here earlier this
year he would play this opening then he
pushed his King side pawns and crushed
people rookie 3 e 4 so now d4 was weak
now d5 is weak and just like Nakamura
did yesterday two days ago wasn't yet
shows a free day two days ago against
Cara Juana
he blocked up the bishop on g2 although
he didn't reverse because he was white
okay now d5 is weak and eventually I win
the d5 pawn
when all of his pawns and then since
Spencer is here I sacrifice the exchange
but only because Spencer's here
and I have good compensation what game
that happened today looks like this
position happened today Spencer no today
very good the game yeah I accept
unlike Carolina i won see and why poets
better than giri we're on board one
carry lose all his games yeah this is
actually very similar except that game
had Queen and rook against Queen night
we have an extra book each that's very
helpful when I check made him it wasn't
hard it was hard for Cara wanted to
check me Gary today had known pieces I
got some pieces yeah so this is terrible
then I gave him the sugar me do here
yeah route d7 was a good move with Queen
c4 mate with advantage he soft it and
then he kept playing like Cara wanna did
against no I'm not come alright then he
resigned yeah yeah and I told you that I
was gonna dominate d4 and I did see even
when the pawn was gone d4 okay so I
learned a lot from that game actually
which leads me to my next game the the
coup the coup d'etat of d4 gay which
made no sense but you guys aren't
getting paid I am advanced and that was
against Lane now I like beating Lane not
because you know he's a grandmaster I
don't like him but when he loses he
complains a lot and when he wins he
doesn't I like to hear the complaining
so I want I like beating him my favorite
Lane story involving me there's a lot of
my favorites but my favorite I'm playing
in DC in the Atlantic open I believe
last round he's not there I set up my
board pieces in Clark he shows up late
and he says can we use my clock and I'm
like okay I take my clock way to put his
clock then he says here's my pieces and
they were like garbage sounds fine well
my sense moving years it's garbage and
he's like you want to use your sent okay
he's really really mad okay his side was
the worst that I ever saw
any quick and that's for a Russian said
that's saying something
okay anyway I mean I'm Angela like one
of these sets if it was 40 years old it
was that's like his that okay so we
played and we remember used his clock
he got use his clock and he lost on time
with eight moves to go and he was like
what and he was looking at his clock
like really funny so yeah I liked
playing Elena he's funny okay so this
gown playing in Italy in 2004 in Chicago
the Chicago open I'm black in the Kings
Indian now this was the Chicago open
were out of seven rounds I had six kings
Indians they gave me Blackhawk know I
had three with black and three with
white I was playing the Kings Indian in
those days okay so I'm black
now I played here in draw Benjamin style
I don't think it males plays like this
c6 okay any good player here plays
knight c6 and some good players play
Knight bg7 but okay I play C 6 and then
Bishop to f5 and now if I didn't play c6
probably I would hang my b7 pawn in my
rook which all of my students do ever
again ok about I play c6 first B 394 so
my idea is to trade all the pieces and
bore him to death okay thank you know he
was in his 70s so yeah good work okay
Bishop b2 and we take and go to e4 again
now I remember there was a game played
at the club here between somebody good
and somebody not good hmm the good play
was some good grandmaster and black was
one of you local guys and I remember
when when Bishop age 3 was played in
that game it's about a year ago the guy
was black was like I don't understand
why he played that that's correct it was
Robert yeah very good good audience here
yeah he's like why do you play Bishop
III I don't get it and I was like what
happened to me years ago okay
so white wants to move the knight and
then play e4 f/4g for and then Matt
Larson would be happy because like yeah
I have all my pawns up okay but okay if
he moves this night I'll play Bishop
takes g2 that's
mission h3 it's very hard to play bitter
today's g2 really I'm looking so now if
it was White's turn to move white would
play something like 9 to g5 and then I
would cry ok so that's the idea behind
Bishop h3 so I take the knight and then
play d5 and now you're like wait a
minute
he said this lecture was about that week
d4 pawn oh okay now I get it okay so I
took tit on f3 and then I made sure the
pawn on d4 couldn't move and he played
rook e1
and I played D takes e4 my best move of
the tournament that required positional
strategical and tactical understanding
and the idea was when he took my knight
which was ridiculous but I mean doesn't
make it I mean it's not ridiculous
because if you see what's happening but
you wouldn't expect that if he takes the
normal move he's normal position then I
play Knight b6 with threats even you can
see and if that's defended somehow
Bishop f1 Queen d3 then I play Knight a4
and then I take I take on d4 as I said I
would before the lecture or I'll throw
in c5 first ok and then I don't know
what why does your White's just worse so
that was pretty awesome so he took my
knight and then okay obviously White's
worse here just has pawns everywhere
crazy
okay e6 so then I'm just gonna triple
quadruple up on the d4 pawn now the
typical player in this room
typical intelligent audience and there's
the three stooges that makes a lot of
fun of this you know you guys would move
around and then I would play rigsy a
rook d7 or d6 I make Alekhine's gun or
some kind of other gun 44 and then I
would take on d4 and I would win but
Anatoli Lane is a grandmaster and he
knows that's going to happen and he's
like man if I lose my d4 pawn my pawn
structure is not too good and I'm down
upon so I can't just let black play rook
da double triple on the D file and take
my pawn I got to do something about that
so he decided to play crazy because then
he won't just lose it'll be a big fight
so he played crazy b5
that way he could never play d5 because
his pawn on c4 was gonna be gone so he
just went totally crazy
he Princeton up h4 h5 h6 d 5 because
strategically you're just gonna lose I'm
gonna play rugby 5 rook h5 rook d5 rug G
and B three or four pawns up so he's
like okay let's go crazy
tanks check and then I resigned cuz of
Maine oh no I know I didn't f6 and King
g8 okay so now I'm up a pawn I think and
I have to passed pawns to passed pawns
is good okay and now we're still
fighting for D for Queen D for very
suspicious and this was a long time ago
so I can actually calculate then dad bad
news for him attacking the h6 pawn and
f5 more crazy moves and d4 yay now my d4
pawn is weak he methodically wins and I
lose the get no that's not what happened
no I'm gonna Queen those ones okay now I
calculate it because I used to be able
to calculate so Matt Larson will
appreciate this instead of winning
simply I like let him take my queen and
meet me but I saw it also so who is okay
Queen g8 yeah if we trade Queens I have
a good endgame yeah it's true and he won
my queen with brilliant tactics and then
I queen yeah okay and then he resigned
although I was surprised he resigned cuz
he can check me like 70 more times but
but I controlled d4 so it's clear now
like you can't yeah so that game I liked
because basically one move okay if we
can go back very slowly I used to be
faster than this if we go back slowly
the key move of this game was d takes e4
and the idea was because his queen is on
d2 I have this night a4 move and this is
this is the
this is this is everything yeah now I'm
threatening the pawn n9a for and his
Center totally collapses otherwise white
would just be a little better so like in
this position Ricky one is a mistake and
he just didn't see the dc4 when I took
on c4 then he saw what was happening so
he tried to bail out and get some kind
of equal position but after 6:00 this
pawn is permanently weak and okay as
other pawns aren't so good either also
suspicious so that was one of my
favorite Kings Indian games and he
didn't complain too much after the game
so I didn't like that I want to hear
some complaining and to finish up with
the complaining story so that you
understand things better many many years
ago when I lived in Europe I befriended
a grandmaster implica from the Czech
Republic which is good at Pachuca and he
said he was playing Blast 2 million so
the Hungarian Grandmaster and the game
ended and Jana said I was winning and
this that in the other and I should have
crushed you and play check I said I
agree and that made me on stir really
mad like what so then they analyzed the
game and obviously Johnson was crazy but
ok but he was mad but I used that in the
last round of Foxwoods I won a game in
70 moves in 6 hours where I squeezed the
guy for 6 hours when the game ended my
opponent I assure members his name but I
won't say it he said I was completely
winning and I said I agree and then I
had to drive home for like all night and
he didn't say anything he's like he
agrees exactly then the later the next
day I put it on my whatever computer it
was then before Rybka so I don't know
and it said I was a point zero five to
winning the whole game he has never
never even the zeros it's like even I
move one I was always better but he was
completely waiting according to him so I
agreed okay and this game my opponent
did not complain he didn't say I was
completely winning so that was
unfortunate okay I liked who my
opponents complain a little bit but yeah
so d4 can be weak even when it's not
isolated because the pawns can't go to
c3 or to e3
so they get attacked if you follow my
lectures and you come to my lectures a
lot my main complaint about my own play
when I'm white as my c4 pawn I play d4
c4 and then my C pawns always getting
attacked and I lose it but in these
games since I see and count on my King
Bishop a lot I do in the Slav I do in
the King's Indian I'm usually attacking
the d4 pawn so my games are in the deep
was it with this idea and if you play d4
and you're not what's his name the guy's
name I can't remember John Boyer thank
you see I'm Anthony John Boyer is
obviously playing III and c3 and then
he's trading them off I'm putting him
back on III and c3 you're not gonna win
his deep line okay because he's playing
the London and the Kali and and the
London Kali okay so when you play him
you're not gonna tag d4 he's got
defended eight times but if people play
more aggressively and try to crush you
they're weakening squares and eventually
if you could attack them with enough
pieces their position will crumble like
this one and I never forget when I play
D takes e4 because it's such a strange
move to give your center pawn away for
the b-pawn for the for the only reason
to play to play Knight a4 and then
you're totally destroying this diagonal
the d4 pawn so after that she should
just resign out of respect but okay he
played on to the bitter end
and eventually I queen the depot which I
still don't get how do they Queen a deep
one I live a deep line but yeah by the
way going crazy was absolutely correct
cuz if he didn't go crazy I'm just gonna
take his deep pawn is gonna be really
bad then you know completely lost and
going crazy was complicated that was
yeah but when you but usually Lane a
very solid positional player when he's
white that crazy is not his specialty
his specialty is slowly grinding and
winning like sort of the way I like to
play okay so when I like sure again
which I'll do next week I'll try to show
similar not d4 but some other square and
then after 64 lectures you're all set
but right you agree
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]